herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video auf einem kanal meine lieben
freunde ich will sie immer wieder
zusammen
warum schlägst du dich immer dicker auf
jeden fall hat sich jetzt befindet sich
hinter der kamera sehen kategorien
überlegt und wir müssen gleich zu einer
kategorie verschiedene unterkategorien
seitdem in dem am ende nichts mehr
einfällt wert verloren
wir verraten okay ich habe versucht
kategorie jeweiligen jeder von euch mal
punkten kann
du bist der moderator
[Gelächter]
neben bushido kapital brauche wieder
sprachenlernen apache
das war schon brutal
da wie dem auch sei bewusst
ehrlicherweise ich bin nicht aus
deutschland in amsterdam paris und
amsterdam die hauptstadt doch schon
gesagt das machst gut ich liebe dich und
deine eltern das ich geboren habe er
seiner tochter verloren
selbst die samba ich vertrage ja auf
jeden fall war
mcdonald's burger king ikea subway in
den auto absolut kostet fünf euro her
ganz tiefe ist so markus kaya aus quark
alles ja ja ja ja jetzt kein standard
belvedere ich verliere etwas gibt es
dennoch
drei parlamentarier am end 3
[Musik]
ich hätte gesagt dass merkel und
schätzle kann mir jetzt sparen
angela merkel nannte mertens horst
seehofer von der lisa von der leyen
ursula von der leyen annegret kramp
karrenbauer martin schulz
angela merkel im kapitol
reister gaffel sion
nina ich habe mich nie war das erklärt
einiges
fußball und die beliebig ausgebaut
das ist ja noch werden
das ist ihm sportlich waren im team und
zwar gibt es noch thema das ist wirklich
sehr sehr traurig
ich kenne meine sachen halter new york
[Musik]
ganz klar die ddr stein morgenpost
gemischtes hat
baywatch berlin gute deutsche mordlust
da gibt es noch socken in sandalen
tagesschau in 100 sekunden habe ich ja
dann sagen wir jetzt mal dabei werden
sie schwanger
[Musik]
deutschland.de keine ahnung ich muss
manchmal links
der podcast mit den ski musik mit
routine alle wege führen nach rom
erzählt er da noch immer so weiter das
will ich sagen kann was es gibt nur noch
hier
stellt euch das heutige rennen meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann nein wir nicht an abonnenten einen
kanal